but to most of the kids that I've spoken
to admit that they have trouble speaking
hi there Steve coffin here and today I
want to talk to you about immersion and
language learning remember if you enjoy
these videos please subscribe click on
the Bell so you get notified whenever I
put up a new video and if you follow me
on a podcast service especially if
you're learning English it's a good
thing to do leave a comment I do
appreciate it so
we hear a lot about immersion the way to
learn a language is to immerse yourself
in the language the image is sort of
jumping into a lake or a swimming pool
and covering yourself in the language
and that way somehow you'll learn the
language
and immersion can have different
meanings and I want to touch on some of
these here particularly as it pertains
to a learning strategy that we can use
so as a young child and I experienced
this as a five-year-old coming to Canada
from Sweden
I started playing with kids I have no
recollection of no longer speaking
Swedish speaking English we spoke
English at home with my parents very
quickly Swedish was gone
I had been immersed in an environment
where I had lots of input from my
friends where I was totally uninhibited
I was simply immersed in the language I
learned it I think a similar form of
immersion is what happens in those
countries where television programs and
movies are in English or in the original
language kids watch cartoons and stuff
in
English and when they go to school
they're already familiar with English so
that's sort of the natural immersion
approach to language learning now before
going on to how we might use immersion
say as adults to learn a language I'd
like to talk about another example of
immersion and that is immersion say in
the school systems for example in the
English-speaking school system in Canada
the French immersion program is very
popular so we have I don't know how many
hundreds of thousands of
English-speaking kids that take all of
their schooling in French so they sit in
a classroom with other English-speaking
kids
and the teacher speaks to them in French
the material they use is all in French
and they learn their chemistry and their
history and their mathematics all in
French so it's called immersion and
those kids end up with a much better
level of comprehension in French than
kids that are in the conventional French
stream in the school system
however and I've had three grandchildren
go to French immersion they don't end up
speaking all that well they have quite
good comprehension but most of the kids
that I've spoken to admit that they have
trouble speaking which is not surprising
because they haven't spoken very much
they speak English with their classmates
or with their friends and once they get
home they speak English and everything
around them in fact is in English so
it's only the classroom situation which
is immersion now on the positive side
with a good level of comprehension if
those kids go off to a french-speaking
place be it the province of Quebec or
France or Belgium or maybe somewhere in
Africa they will very quickly see their
ability to produce the language you know
improve dramatically because they have
good good comprehension and so they will
quickly be able to speak quite well so
it is a good program from that point of
view it gives them a base gives them
vocabulary it gives them comprehension
and the speaking I mean to speak well
you have to speak a lot they don't speak
a lot so they don't speak well so that's
the sort of language immersion programs
in our schools and I think it's not only
French immersion I've heard of Spanish
Immersion Chinese or Mandarin immersion
and other immersion programs on the same
model now how about as an independent
adult learner you sometimes hear people
say well I'll just go to the country and
immerse myself in the language and I
will learn it naturally that's not such
a good strategy because what I have seen
is when people move to a country where
another language is spoken if they don't
make a deliberate effort to learn that
language they're not going to learn it
and they will probably fit into a
pattern of relying on English there are
a number of reasons for this first of
all the locals there who speak Spanish
or Chinese or Czech they're not teachers
they simply want to communicate and if
they sense that you don't communicate in
their language as well as they
communicate in English they're going to
switch to English so whenever I've and I
have used immersion as a strategy but I
always prepare for it so if we are going
to say I want to go to Mexico I want to
go to Italy I want to go to uh you know
wherever Poland and so I and I want to
use visiting the country and even
staying in the country as a way to learn
the language then I have to have a plan
and that plan should consist of making
sure that you hit the ground running in
other words that you are sufficiently
well prepared so that you can take
advantage of being surrounded by the
language and that's what I've done I've
spent a year doing a lot of listening
and reading in Czech then I went to
Prague I set up with teachers so that I
could have that opportunity to speak to
people and then I supplemented that with
whatever random you know encounters I
could have with Czech people but you
can't rely on random people kind of
humoring you in the language that you
are trying to learn the better you speak
that language the more likely they are
to respond to you in that language uh I
often hear people complain they go to
Germany they go to a store they ask for
something in German the answer comes
back in English however if you're German
is good enough they won't reply in
English they'll reply in German they
just want to communicate so if your
strategy is somehow to use immersion as
a means of of you know learning a
language I would say use immersion as a
means of improving in the language and
set yourself as a sort of a plan of how
you're going to get your comprehension
much like those kids in French immersion
in the English school system in Canada
they've got a level of comprehension
they've got a level of vocabulary so
that if they're put in a french-speaking
environment very quickly they'll be able
to speak well so you won't have the
benefit of 10 years of French immersion
in school but you can certainly expose
yourself to a lot of listening and
reading in the language building up your
comprehension so that when you are
arrive in the country
fairly quickly you can sort of start
interacting with people at an adult
level so I think with immersion it
sounds sort of like a magic I'll just go
to Japan and then once I'm there I'll
just learn Japanese it it's probably
more difficult than that and there are
so many things that you can do before
you get to say Japan to ensure that you
hit the ground running so just a a
comment here on immersion it can be a
good strategy but I think it does take
some planning and if you do it right it
can be a great way to develop a high
level of proficiency in a language
thank you for listening bye for now